Eric swalwell who is a congressman from
California
uh he's not happy about it so he tweeted
this
he said breaking representative Byron
Donalds admits on the readout that
speaker McCarthy is kicking me Adam
Schiff and ilhan off our communities
purely out of Vengeance now that's not
exactly what he said he didn't say he
was out of Vengeance he was saying if
you watch a full extended clip well
first off you guys did it so okay that
could be a little Vengeance related you
guys did it now we're gonna do it but
that there are plenty of reasons to do
it he went into the reasons about ilhan
Omar he didn't get a chance to do more
on Schiff who lied about everything
related to impeachments and could it be
that small well has done something
could it be that small well maybe did
something a couple years ago that would
be worthy of Kicking and kicked off the
intelligence committee and could it be
that everyone knows this and that there
was this uh little known I don't know
some would say quite Dapper uh online
video show host who talked to Kevin
McCarthy about that thing about two
years ago didn't swalwell sleep with the
Chinese spy or something I mean yes why
okay that's a good question what we know
publicly
Chinese spy and also remember Senator
Feinstein we found out later the driver
of more than 10 years was a Chinese spy
in Silicon Valley there have been in
pictures together this woman a Chinese
spy creates a relationship with swallow
well with these in the city council
he runs for Congress
she helps she puts interns in his office
do you know how difficult it is to get
on the Intel committee
when swabla was put on the Intel
committee they were in the minority so
they had some fewer seats he was a
sophomore getting partner on the Intel
committee he's kept on the Intel
committee now you know this you put him
on you did not know now you know as a
leader
okay if swallow was in the private
sector he could not get a security
clearance
because he had a relationship with a spy
but it only in America can he be given
the Intel committee where he knows all
the secrets
but there's 200 other Democrats who are
qualified to be on that slot and she
keeps appointing what I know with what
the FBI told me
he should never be on Intel and Pelosi
reappointed an Intel
I don't understand this did you have you
said this to her yes
but this is worse I brought a motion to
the floor
to remove him from Intel put another
Democrat on the Democrats all defended
so you really got to understand the last
part there is key when the Republicans
were not in charge McCarthy was trying
to get rid of swallow as he just said
there he is now the speaker of the house
okay so that clip if if we had a decent
mainstream media and obviously we do not
that clip would be on CNN and across
every newspaper today and what they
would be doing either is if Kevin
McCarthy lied If he if everything he
just said there is a lie and what he's
claiming the FBI told him and all that
stuff and that that Fang Fang the the
Spy didn't staff uh swalwell's office
and all that stuff if it's all a lie
then why wouldn't you air that to
destroy Kevin McCarthy right you'd want
that clip out there my God Kevin
McCarthy is lying about what the FBI
told him and claiming that a Democrat uh
Congressman has been sleeping with the
Chinese spy or at least working with the
Chinese spy at some level but they're
not putting that on there and that tells
you that it's true right that is it
right there so
okay you got it so was this was this as
swallow said was this purely retribution
or was it because ilhan Omar is a noted
anti-semite Adam Schiff is the biggest
liar in all of congress with all the
fake impeachments in Russia Russia
Russia and you were banging a Chinese
spy so this wasn't about vengeance
[Music]